giving up security the city of Las Vegas
Marshals have unveiled a new effort to
protect the tourist Corridor in
particular Fremont Street Lauren negrady
joining us live in The Newsroom this
morning to explain the city's initiative
Lauren good morning to you good morning
John a dedicated group of 10 officers
make up their new flex team the chief of
Public Safety says their goal is simple
disrupt and prevent crime and have less
victims they focus on the tourist areas
like Fremont and the strip and on
juvenile delinquency gun carrying
individuals narcotics and plain closed
investigations Chief Potts says it's a
result of a growing need to be more
proactive in crime hot spots
we're focused right now in our tourist
quarter we want to keep that Fremont
Street area safe and we want to improve
crime and disorder in those areas we
want to have people feel the perceived
that that crime is lower we want them to
feel safer and that's part of this as
well and we do that with high visibility
they Patrol from 4 pm to 2 A.M wherever
they're needed now since the start of
the year they've had more than 500 calls
nearly 60 arrests and 100 plus citations
so far they've busted people for
Narcotics gun possession and a subject
wanted for murder and that's not the
only thing for the Department coming up
in the next half hour a new initiative
added for security live in The Newsroom
Lauren negretti 8 News Now